of homeopathic medicine is in fact just
water with sugar to be fair
[Music]
we're going to talk about today is
actually what it is a philosophy of life
I'm going to start that way and then
we'll talk about skepticism in
particular I think that a philosophy of
life has three components
it has a metaphysics which is
essentially an account of how the world
works I'll give you an example or two in
a minute
there is an Ethics which is an account
of how we should live in the world given
how the world is in other words the two
are connected right in order to figure
out how to live your life how to behave
with other people
uh you need to know something about how
the world is actually put together hangs
together
and then usually although not always
there is a set of practices
to help you implement those two things
particularly the ethics the ethics is
the is the Practical part
for example
so let's say for instance Christianity
uh which is a religion but I I contend
that religions are in fact types of
philosophies of Life there is really not
fundamental difference there
well in terms of them but the physics of
course there is a more or less
benevolent God depending if you're
looking at the Old Testament or the New
Testament uh who created a world is
outside of the world itself etc etc uh
in terms of Ethics uh you can refer to
the Ten Commandments to the teachings of
Jesus uh the apostles and and so on and
in terms of practices you pray you have
communal activities you are you know
reading scriptures and stuff like that
right and you can go through the other
two lines the same is for Buddhism or
stoicism for any kind of other
philosophy or religion so this is what
it means this is what we're talking
about today to have or follow a religion
or philosophy of life
now when it comes to skepticism in
particular Skeptics don't have a
particular a good reputation as a salad
this the cartoon says welcome National
Society of Skeptics the guy on the left
says I don't believe we met the one on
the right says I don't believe you don't
believe we met
I don't really believe anything but
but actually this is about and I'll try
to convince you in the next few minutes
that that is in fact a caricature uh not
not the real thing in fact the word
skeptic comes from the Latin shepticus
which itself is derived from the Greek
skepticos and those words mean Inquirer
or somebody who reflects on things and
tries to learn with an open mind so a
skeptic is not somebody who says has a
knee-jerk reaction every time you tell
him something and says no no no no he's
actually somebody who says okay let's
take a look and by taking a look as
we'll see in next few minutes mostly
that means well what are your arguments
and what is your evidence
uh for why I should believe x z or or
why skepticism has a long history and
most of the initial part of that history
of course is characterized by a bunch of
that wine men but that is changing as
you'll see in a minute arguably it
started out in the western tradition
with Socrates
in the 5th Century uh BCE and then
you'll see a number of people there who
would encounter again in a minute uh
Piro avellis carnidis Marcus Julius
Cicero all the way into the late
Antiquity with success empiricus
then you skip the Middle Ages no
Skeptics in the Middle Ages basically
um because if you were a skeptic in the
Middle Ages you'd likely be burned to
death
um or subjected to others such
unpleasant situations
so we get to the Renaissance directly
and we have people like Michelle de
Montan Rene Descartes the famous I think
therefore I am uh Baruch Spinoza and
most importantly probably arguably David
Hume now as I said you probably noticed
that these are all dead mostly white men
but the situation has been improving
recently uh before talking about modern
skepticism 20th 21st century skepticism
you can see here and you know popping up
a few women like Susan gerbick here at
Hall Carl Tavares Eugenie Scott actually
there's a lot more of that but this is
pretty much the art the historical art
we're talking about this almost
continuous tradition except for the
Middle Ages from the 5th Century BCE
upandil literally now there are two
fundamentally different and yet I will
argue in next few minutes also
fundamentally related types of
skepticism let's refer to them from now
on as ethical skepticism and scientific
skepticism ethical skepticism is in a
sense refers to the second of those
components of a philosophy life that I
was talking about that is how do you
live your life ethics especially for the
greco-romans was really the study of how
to live your life it wasn't just about
determining what is right or what is
wrong in any particular action it was
more broadly an issue of you know what
should I do in life and what kind of
priority should I have how should I
behave with other people that's ethical
skepticism and then there is scientific
skepticism
which is really has to do with the first
component uh that was talking earlier
the metaphysics not metaphysics as as
understood today you know philosophical
zombies pan sarcasm and all that sort of
nonsense sorry uh
but rather metaphysics in the sense of
as I said a picture of the world today
we call it science okay not not really
metaphysics in the in the in the
original sense what I like to convince
you of among other things is that first
of all the two are actually not that
different that that once you see them
from the point of view of a skeptic both
at the ethics and and science actually
fall into the same general kind of
domain and second secondarily that that
it's actually time to bring back a new
form of skepticism or originate a new
form of scriptures where the two are
actually merged uh into one coherent
view more or less according to view of
the world if you're a skeptic you can't
say that you definitely are going to
have a coincident view of the world you
should say you know more or less
probably so let's start with ethical
skepticism and we here need to go very
briefly to Antiquity to the period in
ancient classical uh Rome and and Greece
there were essentially two types of
skepticism I'm gonna introduce both of
them and then we're going to band on one
because it's less relevant to what we're
going to talk about today but for the
sake of completeness I think I should
mention both of them one is actually
referred to and I'll talk about it from
now on as piranism or pieronian
skepticism but piranism is actually uh a
better a short shorthand uh started out
with that guy on the left who was Piero
and uh and then later on the major
author LED Antiquity Sexes empiricals
the other one is referred to as academic
skepticism academic because it actually
took over Plato's Academy after Plato
had died
and from now on I'll refer to it as just
skepticism without the academic part
okay so parentism skepticism but they're
both kinds types of skepticisms and
major people there are Carnitas you see
on the left of the right
and then Cicero
so how do they differ well the different
three major respects first of all in
terms of what philosopher is called a
piece to call epistemology there is how
a theory of knowledge how do we know
things
do we know things in the first place but
how do and if so how uh for the pureness
there is in fact no Firm support for any
kind of opinions which they have heard
that who has dog Mass
outside of evident matters that is you
know there are some things that are kind
of evident and we don't really need to
waste our time talking about it for
instance it's pretty evident that I'm
here talking to you guys and that
there's a certain number of people here
sure we could entertain the possibility
that I'm actually living in The Matrix
and uh or I'm a brain in a bat and all
that but why
there's really no particular reason for
doing that this is everyone but then
there are non-evident matters how you
should live your life is a non-evident
matter it can be debated there is a
question it's a complex question of
evidence arguments etc etc and basically
the appearance rejected anything that
had to do with non-evident matter they
say you know what if it comes to that
you really don't know what you're
talking about you don't have enough
reasons uh to back up your dog mods the
word was Dogma which in in the engine
was just meant opinion
the academic Skeptics on the other hand
say no you can have a certain you can
have opinions and in fact some opinions
are better than others you probably will
never arrive at certain knowledge we had
yesterday panel actually debating the
concept of certain certainty and in in
knowledge
you might not uh have it you might never
get there because human beings you know
what how do we get knowledge we get
Knowledge from our senses and from our
reason and both of them are fallible we
know that sometimes either reason on all
our senses or both can actually lead us
to the wrong conclusion so they're
following so we're never sure that
doesn't mean however that every opinion
is created equal there are some things
that are far more probable than others
more convincing than others and so the
sensible thing to do is to follow
whatever it is that appears to be more
uh like it
now in terms of practice the two spoons
also differed the Pyrenees said that we
should suspend judgment on anything that
is non-evident so
because you don't have knowledge because
you don't have any particular reason to
to go one way or the other you should
just engage in suspension or judgment
now even though I'm not a pyranist I
think this is a great idea today we we
seem to be so damn sure about almost
everything even though we don't usually
don't have any good reasons to be damn
sure and we are so judgmental we tell
other people that there should be living
their lives in a different way that
we're absolutely certain so you know
suspension or judgment that's actually
at least as an exercise it's not a bad
idea
as far as the academic Skeptics are
concerned uh what what happens in terms
of practice you arrive at tentative
opinions based on probability the Greek
word was pitanan which interestingly uh
Cicero translated in Latin as
probabilist which is the root for the
English probability
so you go after you you know you
practice what is probable you you act on
the basis of what appears to you to be
probable given the the facts that you
have available should the facts change
or should the your understanding of the
facts change then you're gonna change uh
your way of acting and then finally in
terms of Ethics that is you know okay so
how do how do I behave therefore in
general what is my goal in life for the
Pyrenees goal of life is tranquility of
mind
sounds boring but you know a lot of
people go after it's like all right I
want to be Serene tranquil and the best
way to do that is to suspend judgment
why
because we are attached to our judgments
our identity uh depends on our judgments
and so when we when our judgments and
our opinions are challenged by somebody
we take it as a personal offense
and that creates you know we get really
upset and riled up and all that sort of
so the notion here is like if you want
to be Serene tranquil in your life just
let go of all those opinions Donna touch
them to your ego and you're gonna be
fine easier said than done
but it's not a bad idea
as far as the academic Skeptics are
concerned on the other hand we should
just live like many other Greco-Roman
schools suggested that is by practicing
uh one of the four cardinal virtues
known as practical wisdom you're
basically going to do whatever it seems
more likely more probable more effective
and more just
and that depends because uh it is based
on opinions the opinion your opinions
themselves are based on probability your
probabilities will change throughout
life so there is no general rule for
living it's just you have to make it up
as you go sounds familiar
so as I said we're going to focus on
this one from now on
now what about scientific skepticism the
second type of skepticism that I was
talking about the first one is being
ethical
what's been defined in a number of ways
by different authors here's Paul Kurtz
in a book called that came out in 1992
called the new skepticism
he said briefly stated a skeptic is one
who is willing to question any claim to
truth asking for certainty for clarity
sorry in definitions consistency in
logic and adequacy evidence in other
words show me the evidence if you're
claiming if you're claiming acts I'd
like to know why you're claiming acts on
what basis are you making that claim
called singing in 1995 in a book called
The Demon hunted World said that the
question is not whether we like the
conclusion that emerges out of a train
of reasoning but whether the conclusion
follows from the premises or starting
point and whether the premises the
premise is true in other words it
doesn't matter what you like to be true
uh what matters is what you think is
true based on evidence based on
questioning your own premises and so on
so forth so that's that's what
scientific skepticism is largely about
scientific skepticism has a huge span of
application
these are some examples up to the left
for instance telepathy
uh
uh the center top Eugenics the notion
that you could you could and should
breed human beings for improvement
uh Bigfoot astrology uh that that guy in
the middle says uh the sign says global
warming is a socialist scam so we're
talking about climate change just say no
to vaccines defend your freedom with
that this this has become particularly
relevant during the covet pandemic uh
UFOs that just water thing refers to
homeopathy
because of homeopathic medicine is in
fact just water with sugar to be fair
and the last one is Jesus uh riding a
dinosaur that represents creationism
which I know you guys think what the
hell is that but in the United States
it's a big deal
so this is the kind of stuff that
typically scientific Skeptics are
concerned with uh okay so to to analyze
these kind of claims and say well why do
you think that there isn't fat such a
thing as telepathy for instance or why
do you think that we should not take uh
vaccines that's on and so forth
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas